[Music]
Disney's animated classic Aladdin is one
of the studio's most treasured movies
but after many years of rewatching it
fans van earth some surprising plot
holes problems and mistakes and the
original animation yippie Kay movie
lovers I'm Jon and in this video I'm
explaining how the live-action remake of
Aladdin fixes many of those issues from
the 1992 movie some spoilers ahead so
take care if you haven't seen the film
yet and don't forget my lighting
giveaway is also running so be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment for your
chance to win let's kick off with a
popular fan theory that the genie failed
to grant Aladdin all of his three wishes
in the original movie wish fulfillment
three wishes to be exact and it's may
under wishing for more wishes it's the
second wish where the genie saves
Aladdin from drowning which is the most
problematic in both the animation and
the new film Aladdin is tied up and has
passed out so even though his hand
brushes against the lamp he can't ask
for a wish from the genie
oh you can't cheat on this one I can't
help you unless you make a wish you have
to say genie I want you to save my life
many fans think that because Aladdin
never explicitly asked for a second wish
I was an official wish say the magic
words that technically the genie never
gave that second wish to Aladdin the new
movie has a neat little fix for this
issue by introducing the idea of gray
areas when it comes to genies granting
wishes hey can you make me a princess
there is a lot of gray area in make me a
prince
so when Aladdin is on the verge of
drowning in the new movie the genie
creates a backdated contract and moves
Aladdin's hand to sign it the document
which is dated the day before Aladdin
was pushed into the sea declares it for
a second wish he wants to be saved from
certain doom this gray area that the
genie uses is a sneaky way to resolve
how many wishes were granted to Aladdin
and it's also used again later in the
movie when the genie grants Jafar his
three wishes and by the way the
filmmakers are clearly aware that the
audience may be checking on how many
wishes are granted in the new movie
because just before he grants a lad in
his first wish to become a prince the
genie says this is an official wish to
those of us who are counting in the
original a whole new world song aladdin
and Jasmine fly all the way from Agrabah
past the pyramids in Egypt through
Greece and finally end up in China all
just one night although it's supposed to
be a fantastical sequence in the
animation it's a pretty tall feat over
such a short time even from magic carpet
as explained in the official art and
making of Aladdin book the live-action
movie aims to give this scene a greater
sense of realism so instead of an
international flight this time the magic
carpet takes jasmine and Aladdin on a
tour of the area and coastlines
surrounding Agrabah changing the
locations in the magic carpet ride and
finishing back in Agrabah rather than
China also gives an opportunity for the
film to further highlight Jasmine's love
for her people and country and speaking
of Princess Jasmine there are some
problematic moments in the original
animation that the filmmakers were
clearly keen to avoid in the new movie
jasmine was only 15 years old in the
original film being a few days away from
turning 16 and so the scene where she
seduces Jafar to distract him from
Aladdin's arrival feels rather icky for
the remake Disney obviously didn't want
to recreate a scene of a 15 or 16 year
old Jasmine in Chains and a skin bearing
outfit who has to seduce a much older
man and is then trapped in an hourglass
that part of the old movie is scrapped
in the new version and updated by giving
Jasmine much more agency in our own song
speechless the name of which by the way
is a neat callback to the moment in the
animated movie where the young princess
is being forced to marry Jafar you will
win Jafar you're speechless I see a fine
quality in a wife I will never marry you
in both stories Jafar's final wish is
his undoing as he ends up trapped as a
genie in a magic lamp beauty pitied
living space the problem with how it
happens in the original film is that
because Jafar is already in command of
the genie he really should have realized
that becoming a genie would make him a
captive the original film basically
relies on Jafar acting rather stupidly
at this point the new movie fixes his
issue in two steps first of all Jafar
specifically asked to become the most
powerful being in the universe more
powerful than the genie himself
notice that Jafar doesn't actually asked
to become a genie presume
because he realizes that that would
involve him being enslaved secondly the
genie uses some of the latitude he has
when it comes to interpreting wishes to
purposely give too far a bad outcome
just before granting Jafar's wished the
genie craftily mutters a lot of gray
area in that then turns him into a
powerful giant red genie which of course
dooms Jafar to live inside a new magic
lamp the big change made to the genies
behavior in the new movie is that the
gray area he has when granting wishes
means he can be a lot more manipulative
for example when Aladdin made his first
wish
the genie went out of his way to warn
him that he needed to be careful with
his words be specific with your words
the deal is in the detail however the
genie deliberately didn't offer too far
the same advice and instead decided to
interpret the villains final wish as
negatively as possible some think fans
of the original animation ones at about
four years was whether the peddler who
introduced the story of Aladdin in the
magic lamp was meant to be the genie in
human form especially as Robin Williams
voiced both characters salam and good
evening to you worthy friend perhaps you
would like to hear the tale it begins on
a dark in fact as the filmmakers
acknowledged in a blue-ray commentary
for the film they had always planned for
the connection between the peddler and
the genie to be completely obvious by
having the peddler reappear at the very
end just after aladdin and Jasmine s
final kiss as the original work print
for the movie also shows happy end of it
are you sure you don't want about this
leg like I told you things are never
quite what they seem the good news is
that in the 2019 movie it's very clear
that the genie and the narrator at the
beginning of the film of one and the
same which fixes the lost connection
from the 1990s animation when Prince Ali
parades in to Agrabah and stomps into
the palace on his elephant it's a true
spectacular and fun moment in the
original movie however it seems rather
strange that everyone simply takes the
new Prince Ali at his word about where
he's come from and whether he's even a
real Prince Prince Ali Ababwa
of course I'm delighted to meet you to
fix this and make things more realistic
in the live-action movie it's made clear
that both Jasmine and Jafar have never
heard of a bad war and they both
investigate further
Jasmine confronts Prince Ali telling him
that she can't find a bad boy on any of
her maps Aladdin does however manage to
continue his ruse with a little help
from the genie who adds a bad boy onto
one of Jasmine's maps
although Jafar figures out quite quickly
that a fatwa is a made-up place in the
original animation just before the Cave
of Wonders allows Aladdin to enter it
instructs him although those
instructions seem pretty straightforward
in other words don't touch anything
except the lamp some fans have quibble
that there's a few occasions where
Aladdin and Abu do just that with no
penalty for example they both have
contact with the magic carpet and
Aladdin also clearly puts his hands on
some of the rocks at one point the
live-action movie fixes this issue by
modifying the caves rules this time
Jafar tells Aladdin to take no other
treasure and to take nor think but the
lamp it's a subtle change but the
difference is that in the animation the
rule was basically don't touch and in
the live-action it's don't take that
small rule change clarifies that it's
okay to touch or step on anything as
long as you don't try to take it this is
doubly important in the new movie
because the cave is littered with
treasure everywhere so much so that it's
impossible for Aladdin to navigate his
way through without touching any of it
the depiction of the characters and
culture and the original Aladdin is
something that Disney's been criticized
for as it draws on numerous negative
stereotypes when the film was released
in 1992 the lyrics to the opening song
Arabian Nights originally included the
line where they cut off your ear if they
don't like your face to address some of
the criticism around that song for the
home entertainment release Disney
changed the line to where it's flat and
immense and the heat is intense but they
did retain the next line it's barbaric
but hey it's home many still objected to
the use of the word barbaric and so for
the remake Disney rewrote much the song
to avoid controversy this time around
likewise in the new movie when Jasmine
can't pay for the food she gives to a
couple of poor children the merchant
doesn't threaten to chop off her hair
like he did in the animation do you know
what the penalty is course there is a
little nod to the original moment though
in how he grabs hold of her arm but
that's as far as it goes
the francilee lyrics have also been
corrected and updated the original line
sundae salam has been changed to friday
salam to reflect correctly that friday
is the muslim holy day and the line in
prince ali that he's got slaves he's got
servants and flunkies has had the slaves
reference removed and been updated too
he's got ten thousand servants and
flunkies jasmine and Aladdin's clothing
and the new film has also been updated
to be more practical realistic and less
revealing it's unlikely that a princess
would have walked around in that top all
of the time so now Jasmine gets some
beautiful new outfits but which keep her
midriff covered up the costume designers
added a nod to Jasmine's bare midriff in
the animation though by adding a
flesh-colored piece of fabric and a
tummy area of Jasmine's dress likewise
in the animated movie Aladdin is bur
chested when he isn't Prince Ali but
Disney covered him up with a shirt so
they wouldn't have a topless Aladdin in
the live-action version and the three
harem girls in the one jump ahead song
have also been replaced this time around
with a group of modestly dressed
schoolgirls now did you spot any plot
holes or mistakes in the new movie let
me know in the comments below and
subscribe to enter my Aladdin giveaway
congratulations to the winner of my Game
of Thrones giveaway contact me via email
from my about page so I can send you
your prize tapleft to learn all about
jasmine and Jafar's dark secret history
in my Ladin Theory video or tap write
for another video you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippie Kay movie lovers